we're stuck stuck in quarantine waiting
for arrival test results nine days after
returning from a christmas trip to see
grandparents what are we spending the
money on what are we expending the
resources on it's a question more and
more people are asking with testing
capacity stretched and some symptomatic
people unable to get a pcr test while
returning travelers already have a
negative one taken within 72 hours of
arrival except for a small spike at
christmas traveler test positivity rates
hover around one percent and often less
while community positivity rates are now
at 28 percent much better to direct
those pcr
testing and the things available at
airports to population testing we're
kind of flying blind to try to keep
flyers to get them tested tracking every
case isn't
you know really necessary for a
surveillance perspective canada's top
doctor says testing a sample of
returning travelers may be a better way
to go it is a capacity
[Music]
drain on the systems as a whole while
the health minister refuted that in an
interview on the west block those
resources that we're using at the
borders to protect canadians and to
protect people traveling through the
borders those resources are different
from the resources that providence and
territories have access to they use
their own resources we use our own
resources the president of the canadian
chamber of commerce isn't buying that
given the overall backlog at labs when
all that you have is a hammer
everything looks like a nail
and to be seen to be doing something has
been focusing on the border instead of
saying rationally how should we be using
our resources the chamber of commerce is
part of the canadian travel and tourism
roundtable which this week called for an
end to on arrival pcr tests dr tam
didn't go so far as to recommend that
but said she would advise against using
resources to sequence every traveler
test given omicron is so prevalent
everywhere abigail beeman global news
ottawa